big news on the supreme court long time
liberal justice stephen breyer
is retiring he will be at the white
house later today where president biden
will make a formal announcement what
this means is democrats will have their
best chance since 2010 to see one of
their picks sit on the nation's highest
court jan crawford is at the supreme
court for us jan good morning
good morning tony you know justice
breyer let president biden know last
week that he intends to retire this
summer but he had resisted pressure from
progressives last year to step down so
president biden could replace him now
he's making this decision his own
ladies and gentlemen judge stephen
breyer
nominated in 1994 by president clinton
breyer has been a pragmatic justice a
defender of civil rights and a staunch
opponent of the death penalty engaging
and well liked by his colleagues he also
likes to talk and listen as he told me
in this conversation in 2019 i might sit
down with a colleague and say or try to
change their mind yes i might
but i've learned over time
that everyone on the court of course
wants everyone to agree with them about
everything
all the time there's long been
speculation about when breyer an older
justice though still as mentally sharp
and active as ever would retire but
after the death of justice ruth bader
ginsburg the drum beat from progressives
got louder when exactly
i should retire or will retire
has many complex parts to it i think i'm
aware of most of them his retirement
will not change the ideological makeup
of the court which is now split with six
conservative justices and three liberals
but the new nominee could well change
the face of the supreme court in the
presidential campaign mr biden promised
an historic choice i'm looking forward
to making sure there's a black woman on
the supreme court a promise the white
house says he will keep the president
has
stated and reiterated his commitment to
nominating a black woman to the supreme
court and certainly stands by that the
top candidates all are judges the
front-runner 51-year-old federal appeals
court judge katangie brown-jackson a
harvard law school graduate who is a law
clerk for justice breyer without a doubt
being a law clerk for justice breyer was
one of the most rewarding professional
experiences of my life
now president biden shortlist has
several other highly qualified
african-american women including
california supreme court justice leandra
krueger south carolina federal judge
michelle chiles she by the way a
favorite of biden alley congressman
james clyburn but whoever the president
decides to nominate justice breyer said
he intends to stay on until his
successor is confirmed that's probably
going to be sometime
in the late summer nate
jan thank you